White House officials saying some of the
hardest hit cities including New York
Detroit and New Orleans could see
infections peak in the coming days right
now there are nearly 300 and 38,000
coronavirus cases in the US with at
least 96 hundred deaths as the president
and the White House warned the week
ahead could be devastating this is going
to be the hardest and the saddest week
of most Americans lives quite frankly
this is going to be our Pearl Harbor
moment our 9/11 moment I will not say we
have it under control Margaret that
would be a false statement we are
struggling to get it under control and
that's the issue that's at hand right
now
this would be probably the toughest week
between this week and next week then
there'll be a lot of death unfortunately
this is outnumbered and I'm Melissa
Francis here today's harris faulkner
host of kennedy on fox business kennedy
is back with us welcome my friend
attorney and Fox News contributor Emily
campano is joining us as well and dr.
Marty Meharry physician and professor at
Johns Hopkins University and a Fox News
contributor and he is outnumbered
dr. Meharry let me start with you where
do you think we are in this do you see
any glimmers of hope I do but I would
caution against people over interpreting
one number looking better over the
course of one or two days we saw this in
Italy when we got excited that their
numbers had gone down from say 500 to
430 and it turns out that the numbers
are best looked at as a three day moving
average so I wouldn't over interpret
things I think sheltering is working I
think we're not seeing the massive spike
that was possible but I would just brace
for the next two weeks to be a rough
period not just the next week
Kennedy your thoughts I'm very grateful
that the the spike that dr. McKay is
referring to has not happened but I
agree we shouldn't be falsely confident
and you you have to find the joy in the
little things that being quarantined has
shown us and you know we have to follow
all of this information he's absolutely
right you can't just abstract one number
and take that as a sign that everything
is fine or another number and use that
as a hysterical point to fear that
you're going to be stuck inside forever
we will come through this at some point
and a little bit of good news is going
to go a long way but we should still
snuggle up as though there's a storm
upon us yeah Emily I mean it's gonna be
increasingly difficult I think as time
goes on as different parts of this
nation are in different parts of this
crisis you know for some states it
hasn't really hit them very hard yet
places like New York you know maybe
we've seen an APEC so we're getting
close to it or whatever the numbers will
show us but that doesn't mean that it's
not going to get worse in other parts of
the country as we recover what are your
thoughts exactly for example Washington
DC predicts its peak will come in June
or July so that's why I think for all of
us sheltering in place at home it's
important to view this sort of as a
marathon right not a sprint and while we
see certain hot zone major cities
experience potentially the apex or the
ramp up to the apex right now there are
other major cities that are frankly
months behind and so it's important for
all of us I think as Kennedy said to
snuggle up and stay comfortable at home
but really to appreciate the fact that
this is not going to resolve itself in
the next week or two that contrary to
many of our news cycles or national
conversations that last sometimes just
two or three days this is really a
months long process and the best thing
that we can do for all of us is to stay
home in the interim while obviously
ramping up support for the medical
communities in the different surgeon
cities in Harris I would ask for your
thoughts and also I may be the only one
I'm not hearing doctor Meharry I'm sorry
too
our business here Oh puppy here but go
ahead and your thoughts on this and
maybe you have a question for him
actually I just have a question for him
and I want to take the conversation a
little forward as we await the governor
of New York to join us I wonder if he'll
even touch on this so part of going
forward with an apex as I understand it
dr. McQuarry is not just about the the
number of cases and the number of deaths
that break us you know that break our
hearts every day but also the number of
recoveries and that's particularly
interesting to me today from what I'm
reading that there is this push now a
blood drive to try to find plasma donors
if you will so that we can look at their
blood as a possible answer for treating
and and you know supportive care for
some of the people who are really
suffering the most among us with kovat
19:00 what is your thought on the
survivors of this and how they play a
role you know
Harris survivors of any infectious
diseases have long been an important
piece of cracking the code on how to get
beyond an infection we saw with HIV
we've seen it with other infections and
99% of people recover from kovat 19
infection that means there's going to be
a lot of discharges a lot of recoveries
and those people have in Hanan bodies
those antibodies are already being
extracted at hospitals like my own and
other places so not just can those
antibodies be used but they can be
duplicated in a laboratory to try to
come up with a good therapeutic thank
goodness one of the other stats that
I've been hearing is that you know we
are ventilator use is down now as well
I'm here in New York at least we're
seeing a slight dip in that does that
say to you maybe that people are
catching the symptoms earlier and maybe
taking better care of themselves so they
don't get to that point or how would you
explain that and then kind of be a
cheese feel free to go go ahead and next
I think it shows that sheltering in
place is working look I'm personally not
interpreting the slight decrease as a
decrease
interpreting it as a non spike and so
I'm not finding any comfort in one or
two days of numbers because the doctors
on the ground are telling me they're
incredibly busy there was a piece in The
Washington Post just recently showing
that many hospitals are not reporting
everything and it's not that they're
malicious it's that they're busy if
somebody dies from kovat 19 and you've
got another patient short of breath you
go and you take care of them reporting
to the Public Health Department is not a
super high priority when you've got a
battlefield